my name is brittany steffen and i
am a sex therapist i'm sebastian and i'm
the rock star of the world aka i'm a
drag superstar
how old were you when you lost your
virginity i waited till i was 22. was it
special
oh no most people when they lose their
virginity it's not special
i've been glad turquoise two
inexperienced people get together to
make something
if you stuck two inexperienced people
and said drive this car
snobby is not gonna be cute are you
ready to meet these wonderful people
absolutely how well do you think you're
gonna do i think i'm gonna do well
because
i've prepared some questions are they on
your phone they're on my phone okay
are they on your phone are you being
rude right now
okay okay they're on your phone good i
thought you know you would i
pulled out your phone middle computer
interview
hey man yo we didn't name this channel
for no reason we're about to cut you
are you dating no what do you do for
work i am a software engineer
he's been laid before oh yeah you think
so
that's my guess i've just been saying
you know i'm mad at you how much money
do you make being a software engineer
like 150 000 a year i don't think he's a
virgin because he makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year and i'm pretty
sure anybody
would be doing that
[Laughter]
he bases himself a witch but whatever is
this
can you unbutton three buttons from my
shirt i'm consenting to this
okay okay go for it
virgin
[Laughter]
what's your answer uh i am not a virgin
i'm trash
i'm a trash human yeah
like whenever yeah
do the lap don't worry i have to have
this because i reject virgins all the
time
really boy for girls uh for girls got
her v card i'm not touching that nobody
you reject
them all the time okay i'm not going to
make it sound like i'm out here like you
russian
hell no i'm not i'm not going out of my
house that's something we understood
you get proposed by a lot of virgins
that's what i understand people who
approach me try to like get on a dating
tip
and then i can smell like there's a bit
of an experience there and then from
there
once i discover that the rv you know i'm
like nah i'll pass i can't understand
i don't want to do that to some people
especially if they're older
i assume that losing it is a bigger deal
or it might be more special to them
and while i've used as something i enjoy
and all that stuff
i don't want to take that from somebody
who views it drastically different than
i do
i don't want anything and also all that
virginity out of you
i don't want to for me it's a reciprocal
thing if you can't
reciprocate it's like you get any
experience it's like i i don't get off
i'm being like i'm going to teach you
everything girl like that's not sexy to
me so
that's mine the worst thing is there's a
lot of people that they get off on oh
yeah she's a virgin and then that's the
like why would you want and then explain
what uber driver that's your first time
driving oh hell
yeah you know what i mean how old were
you when you lost your virginity i was
19.
but i haven't seen like the past seven
years oh wow that's a piece of
information that could change tonight
my name's turquoise
okay girl okay
that's wrong she saw he was tall
then she heard his income level man
is not a v yo i'm mad at her though
girl shoot your shots do your thing god
damn it
she went in yeah
live your life uh i have clammy hands
did you just make a pass yeah
oh did you i never did you know
i'll tell we'll talk after yeah yeah
yeah hi i'm brittany i'm colin how old
are you
yes 16 maybe 12 12
oh man i'm 18. what's your sexual
preference you like women orientation
i think i'm straight yeah my my vibe is
that he he's not church boy
[ __ ] you yeah my vibe is that he's
not okay no worries
i feel like he's a little sneaky like
he's taking just to the back at the
parties and
stuff i don't think you're a virgin
because your
openness to kink makes me think that
you've gone past the
vanilla sticks and moved on to some fun
kinky stuff you're correct vanilla
doesn't mean that you're virgin or
not it doesn't mean that
it's just
i think everyone nowadays pride
themselves on being like raw fur kinky
or all this other stuff and i find it
kind of cringy
so are you dating anybody no i've like
dated people but not like been in a
relationship
how do you feel about systems with
another woman would you be into that no
you're not into that how do you feel
about with another guy
definitely not no trains are being ran
on here
dammit
[Music]
she know what a train is no i don't
think she knows oh
this [ __ ] is wild that's a
sentence i don't think i've ever said in
my life
she bout to get a train ring on it
hey yo tyrone i'm about to run the train
yo this is is yo what's wrong with this
dude
hey man let me just say if you running a
train on somebody always be the
conductor
yeah you don't want to be the last wagon
have you met anyone in person that you
met online
yes like i would go on dates with people
that i've met online have you been to
anyone's house
yeah uh i don't think she is i don't
think she's a virgin
something's off i don't know what it is
but someone's off just my vibe from her
like yeah i don't think she has any
experience you're not a virgin
i'm gonna go with virgin i don't think
you're a virgin because
you look like this and you're not
wearing a bra are you wearing a bra
no
what's dance i'm a free nippled virgin
that makes sense can i ask you questions
you can ask me as many questions okay
fill in the blank baby can you put your
blank in my blank
uh in my hand baby can you put your
in my hands
i'm just i just want to check all dots
here yeah no i mean
okay good don't you don't have to say it
out loud sorry mom
i'm gonna go ahead and say he is not a
virgin and if he is then he won't be
after today
you know what we can appreciate we
appreciate it it's funny when you
appreciate it's funny
but it's also
very on the edge of living on the edge
of me too
imagine yeah imagine if a straight dude
was saying that to a lesbian girl
oh no if you don't you dig what i'm
saying that's one of those things like
i think dudes often get a pass because
they're characters there isn't but
you know they're they can be hyper
aggressive in a way that's super
bad super bad lesbian
wouldn't know because i don't see it but
i'm just telling you from my experience
what i've seen like
i've seen dudes do stuff i'm like you
get away with that
just because you know the whole thing
but the the rainbow flag and i'm like i
get it skittles great
but we're being honest
that's not okay i am a virgin damn it
turquoise
you are i am you live with your
girlfriend
why aren't you sleeping together i grew
up in a pretty conservative christian
home it still has some amount of
influence over sort of the way i think
what's your type dark hair the guy's not
like too pasty
hella specific do you watch
i do i was like really scared to say
that for a while but oh
sad are you single now no i'm
dating somebody you like him yeah like a
lot a lot a lot
yeah okay yeah is anyone in this
scenario very religious
my dad is from yemen so he's muslim but
not like intense
sneaky dicky they listen come from a
really like conservative family
oftentimes don't mean nothing sometimes
you go the opposite opposite way
they're like allah this way and they're
like on this way
that's how it works so i'm not eating
bacon yeah i mean but you know
congratulations to her
she looks uh fantastic so good for her i
don't think you're a virgin because of
how excited you were to talk about
your boyfriend she is not a virgin and
if you are then we're gonna
figure that out soon i'm not a virgin
good
hi oh my god hey michael your eyes are
like hi yeah
thank you how are you i'm 32.
what's your preference i'm same
okay surprise hub or x-tube
neither you don't watch pornography
you're a rare
human being what's your background um
raised christian
yo alba what's your background i'm from
ethiopia what's your background white
person
uh i'm i'm christian
i'm not mad at it but it's just it's
funny to see the difference
and then my dad said the family was
catholic so we're 32
we're getting [ __ ] if you haven't got
nothing yet i don't know what's gonna
happen
when did you come out i would say i was
28.
i feel like since you came out so late
you probably were a secret
okay the mouth was working i think i
understand what you're saying
i can see you being a virgin what's the
answer yes i am
yeah awesome tell me you'll tell me all
about it
my religious background that was always
stressed to me that
you have after you get married whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
that thing says why are you cringy i
don't know i feel like this whole video
is just like
do you have a religious background
you're probably a virgin i feel like
there's a whole pattern this whole video
do you have any guy friends yeah i think
a lot of them don't really understand it
but um they're supportive
of me as a person i support you thank
you and i really hope that you find
mr wright that's gonna break that back
wide open
and marry you but not necessarily in
that order
right hopefully it's in that order
all right uh i mean what was the inside
of this video
you tell me there's no inside they don't
try to make inside videos which is fine
i think i think if you're just doing a
video to just like that's okay that's
what these videos are
when i watch a cut video i'm like a
little for 15 minutes and i'm like but
sometimes you try to be the devil's
advocate you try to be like you know
what no
maybe they try to be hey you do that on
jubilee videos yeah because jubilee
pretends like they're trying to do
something impactful
actually it's not the same thing if i go
to fast food i don't complain that it's
fast food
i don't go to mcdonald's you're like man
why isn't there real meat in this bun
man this lettuce looks like it's been
here for seven days your salad is trash
mcdonald's you know what i mean like i
know what i'm going when i go to
mcdonald's
what i don't like is when you're doing
fine cuisine and then you give me a
mcdonald's bun
then i get offended but you know overall
like
you know these videos are fine they're
empty they're empty calories and it's
cool there's nothing wrong with that
and as far as like being insightful not
at all it's just one of those things
around mine
it's one of those days yeah let's just
just take it for what it is but uh
i don't have fun for a little laugh here
and there but beyond that i don't think
it has to be impactful
that's it i'm mad at it anyways that's
it for today uh just make sure that
you subscribe if you watch this
subscribe and we have merchandise we'll
check that out as well oh and if you
want discord
highlight is
me